hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow Constantine video so so
amazing and there wasn't even a villain
in the episode I mean I mean there were
kind of a villain in the flashbacks but
the episode was really about mending
things like mending Sara's soul mending
the relationships between the group
members so just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet real
quick reminder to the reverse flash ring
giveaway is new again this week so all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so start by explaining the big
stuff first Constantine in this DC TV
universe what you know what's going on
in the future well the deal that they
did for this episode was just for the
one episode they don't have any contract
sign for Matt Ryan to come back on any
of the shows they were barely able to
make the schedule work to get him on out
because he's shooting a movie and he's
doing a Broadway play he's just a really
busy guy but he's totally willing to
come back and do the character so I
think what they'll probably try to do is
bring him on legends of tomorrow
sometime in the future
and he gave Oliver that magical tattoo
the Chinese characters so they're just
like a number of different ways to
insert him especially now the arrow is
doing magical storylines
so no more Constantine on screen for the
foreseeable future but they might
reference him like they might they might
do the phone call thing for they
reference advice that they got from him
in the past but on the top 5 WTF so
number 5 Oliver's new campaign manager
who you might recognize from Suburgatory
advises him to break ties with Laurel
because of what happened with the Queens
gambit he thinks he'll completely you
know air quotes sink him just like the
Queens gambit this is a really important
storyline because it gets to the core
about how Oliver feels about Laurel in
the rest of her family for that matter
now this campaign strategist doesn't
know anything about what happened he
still believes the lie that everybody
died in that Queens gambit Oliver's the
only survivor so he doesn't know
everything the Oliver's been through
with the Lance family since that
happened and where things stand right
now he's actually not super close to
Laurel I think they have a certain
respect for their history but they
haven't seemed super close this past
season especially since Laurel decided
to become the Black Canary the stuff
with Sara only makes it worse but on to
number 4 Oliver finds out that sara is
still alive WTF what happened to spa day
the really important thing I think they
did with this Sara storyline is not tell
it completely from Oliver's perspective
he's almost like a bystander they really
tell it from Thea and Laurel
perspective like Laurel is the only one
that has the level head she's like look
I did this because I knew you wouldn't
approve you have this crazy double
standard where you keep secrets from us
so we have to start keeping secrets from
you and then tangentially we also get
Thea's perspective where she feels so
remorseful that she's ready to dial she
even tells Sarah when she comes to her
hospital bed I want you to do it I want
you to kill me how hard up must she be
that she's ready to die which I talked a
little bit about some of the
inconsistency in her character in last
week's episode sometimes they shoot
episodes out of order so maybe that's
why she seems so bipolar but on to
number three
Sarah versus Thea is one of the best
speedy fights all season now Willa
Holland and the people that do stunts
for Willa Holland have been doing an
amazing job this the speedy stunt work
is great completely on point in her
working with the scream of sticks with
Oliver is just like last season when
they were on the island training
together but sara is still always gonna
be the more powerful fighter so she just
dances on Thea's face and even though
they pretty much fixed her in this
episode like they rebound her soul to
her body Sarah is still gonna be a
little bit crazy but even though Thea
goes down hard you can you can still see
that she's actually turning into a
really badass fighter so I think in the
next season or two you'll see some
really awesome speedy stuff and now that
Laurel and Oliver have galvanized their
friendship I'm hoping we'll see Oliver
train Laurel finally because it seems
like he keeps putting that off like I'm
not gonna train you I'm not gonna train
you I feel like laurels overcome every
single one of his objections like that's
the point of this episode that Oliver
finally opens up so he has to start
training her at some point on the number
two though WTF reveal Diggle learns that
his brother was actually a crime lord in
the Middle East during the war the
producer said that this in no way gives
Diggle closure so this hasn't closed the
book on his brother by any means but I
think what they're trying to do with a
lot of these characters this season is
blur the lines between good and evil
like you have Harrison wells in the
flash who's not a villain but he's not
good either
like he's not nice so just because
someone like Quentin has been really
dirty doesn't mean that they're not a
good character anymore so I think Diggle
is gonna soften up a little bit when it
comes to Quentin and if anybody on arrow
is listening right now please write more
Diggle and Quentin scenes that was one
of the most fun parts in the episode the
two dudes with the lowest level of tech
literacy have to have
damian darhk-- in speaking which mr.
terrific of course he is actually
wearing the Fairplay jacket and gave a
shout out for being the bronze medal in
the decathlon limpets big big comic book
Easter egg that Tex storyline is all
about surfacing the atom if you didn't
see the teaser for next week they're
gonna answer a lot of questions about
what's going on with Ray Palmer and
that's all flowing out of that felicity
mr. terrific storyline and finally out
of my number one WTF moment Constantine
comes into the arrow verse and he's now
old friends with Oliver he shows up in
the flashbacks first Oliver meets him
helps him recover magical artifact to
keep it out of the hands of Baron Reiter
here but then tells him that the island
itself is a magical Nexus just full of
all kinds of places that people can get
themselves into trouble
the name Lee Anne you literally means
purgatory so of course it's a magical
nexus so they can potentially mine the
island for more magical storylines that
they wanted to the location that
Constantine made Oliver taken to on the
island which is one of many magical
places there but as I mentioned he uses
the grimoire to transfer the tattoo to
Oliver it's those are Chinese characters
and he says this is insurance you'll
know how to use it when you need to so
we can either see Oliver use that in the
flashbacks or we could see him use it in
present-day because I believe he still
has the tattoo so I don't know if it's a
one use only kind of thing but I'm
hoping that they actually tie it in with
the damien darhk's storyline in
present-day though when Constantine
shows up he makes the joke about bonding
someone's soul to their body he says oh
I've done this once before maybe like a
year ago he's just making a joke about
Constantine season 1 on NBC they did
something similar in an episode of that
so hit that's just him making fun of
Constantine being canceled but let me
know in the comments what was your
favorite thing from the episode was it
Constantine just just coming on or was
it them going to the spirit world to
recover Sarah's soul the sword fighting
the Constantine was doing those people
they were fighting those are just random
spirits it wasn't anyone in particular
but like I said don't expect to see
Constantine again anytime soon but they
might reference him or reference things
that he has said in the past or advice
that he's given they're gonna have to
figure out how to defeat damian darhk--
and that's going to require magical
knowledge so they have to get that from
somewhere and if anything like the next
most magical thing that's going to be
happening on the show is Hawkman and
Hawkgirl speaking of which next week is
episode 6 episode
is the Vandal Savage crossover episode
with the flash so we're actually gonna
be meeting Hawkman pretty soon that's
why Ray Palmer is coming back in a big
way next week just because they have to
introduce this legends of tomorrow cast
before episode 8 so what's gonna happen
next is is I'm gonna do my agents of
shield video they finally reveal two
lashes so I won't post that spoiler here
I'll save that for my agents of shield
video and then I'm gonna do a Supergirl
video and then there's the Warcraft
trailer on Friday that should be like
Friday morning well you guys wait for
all that stuff you can click here for
this week's episode of the flash buy one
of the best episodes this season so far
and you can click here for my Gotham
video that I just posted thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight